[Music]
hi I'm Dave Hill writer and mrs. hashtag
news and we can land on a comet but we
can't land on the moon no that was a
hoax don't be cheap oh yeah definitely
there's on TV this week's top story is
net neutrality and I know you already
know everything about that so I guess I
can just oh wait you don't know you've
been pretending this whole time and
every time net neutrality comes up in
conversation you just nod your head and
say oh yeah I get terrible service in
elevators and everyone looks at you so
you could be change the subject of
reptiles because that's the only subject
you really know anything about yeah I
thought so well don't worry because I
know your time is valuable I'm gonna do
my best to catch you up in under a
minute
net neutrality is a concept that simply
means everyone should have the same
access to the same Internet no if ands
or Kim Kardashian buts about it and yes
I know what you're thinking I saw it on
the thumbnail - it made me click on the
video we'll get to it very soon so why
is this news again again again again
because our dear president barack obama
wants internet to be legally
reclassified as an essential utility
like electricity or water or that thing
you see on your computer yes yes and
that would make it so that internet
providers can't punish you for accessing
the Internet in any other way than what
makes them the most profit you could
continue to have your xxx open tabs full
of shake it off covers and binge
watching every season of Pretty Little
Liars which maybe you started as an
accident but it acts is actually pretty
addicting but if net neutrality fails
the internet will be back to what it was
like when you were 11 years old in your
middle school library and you're trying
to Google boobies but it's blocked
except now you're an adult in your own
home still googling boobies except the
internet company won't show you them
because they don't want you to Google
poopies they brought you to Bing boobies
I'm low on time stay with me okay
basically if someone asks you at a party
what your stance is on net neutrality
you take a moment like you're really
pondering it and then you say obviously
it's important to support because the
Internet is the central nervous system
of all mankind everyone should be able
to access that information
equally information ultimately just
wants to be free huh how did I do you
way way over time alright well give me a
break man it's my first time and
obviously I'm pretty passionate about
the subject
[Music]
and now for the challenge portion of
hashtag news for today's challenge I
will deliver the news well beach balls
are thrown at my face go for the first
time ever the European Space Agency has
landed a spacecraft on a freaking comet
that's like trying to land a team of
ragtag oil drillers on on an asteroid
that's headed straight for earth about
to kill everyone on it including
Aerosmith's daughter and if die hard a
new Batman can't agree to get along and
put alright moving on not satisfied with
six second video limits on their video
recordings new company Oh Cho is trying
to outdo vine by introducing an app that
lets you record eight seconds of video
check out my first Ocho uma Gustavo Cho
working with the Ocho app got an eight
seconds to play with what do you think
Ted what are you doing the extra two
seconds huh and now why you clicked on
this video in the first place
Kim Kardashian's butt bring it in guys
I'm literally back in that awesome
she posed nude on the cover of a
magazine and her butt supposedly broke
the internet in reality all it did was
break down barriers for women welcome
equal pay for all I'm kidding it's
terrible she's terrible and she also did
a full frontal cover but we're not gonna
show you that if you want to Bing those
groupies on your own time leave me out
of it and finally while that but didn't
break the internet we asked you to tweet
at us what would break the Internet
here are some of our favorites that John
Kelly says maybe if she sat on it yes
John Kelly Dan right there man at
awkward Holland Justin Bieber as Batman
he'd be awful he'd be absolutely awful
at fimo Harry Potter film with Hermione
wearing Star Wars bikini yeah yeah I
think that would that would do it okay
what happens now subscribe but this is a
magazine yeah alright subscribe to new
media rockstars hit like if you've ever
been goobies and oh let us know in the
comments what challenges you want to see
next week on hashtag news all right
you've been great guys
I've been Gabe goodbye why would you do
that
that's a really uncool I'm done I'm done
with this